Your presence at times can speak louder
than your words. My name is Matt
Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to this
Quick Thinks episode of Think Fast, Talk
Smart the podcast.
Today I'd like [music] to walk you
through best practices for helping you
to make sure you convey confidence and
authenticity in your communication. The
goal here is not to make everyone
communicate the same way, but rather to
introduce you to fundamental best
practices based on academic research
that can inform what you do with your
body and your voice.
The very first thing people see about
you is how you hold your body.
Three rules to follow. You want to make
sure that you are big,
balanced, and still.
What I mean by that is you want to pull
your shoulder blades back so that you
extend your chest. We're not pulling our
elbows back. We're not puffing out our
chest, but we pull our elbows down and
shoulders down. Allow your hands to drop
down by your side. This way you look
very [snorts] big. Now we want to make
sure our head is straight as well. Many
of us tilt our head or we lean when we
communicate. We want to be still
and balanced.
To make sure we're still, we have to
think about our feet. Many of us when we
stand, we stand with our feet facing out
to a 45-degree angle, like a penguin or
a duck. This actually opens up our hips.
If you've done any dance, yoga, or
martial arts, you know that having your
feet out like this makes it easy and
flexible for you to move.
The problem is when you're standing up
and speaking, we don't want to be
swaying from side to side. It can be
very distracting.
For my Stanford MBA students when they
have to do a big assignment, we'll
digitally record them and I make them
watch the recording without sound on 2x
speed and they see themselves swaying in
the wind. How do we fix this? We take
our feet and we make sure they're
parallel underneath our shoulders. We
put one foot slightly in front of the
other and maybe even come up on our
tiptoes and settle down. That pulls the
weight forward.
So with our shoulders pulled down, our
arms by our side, our head straight, and
our feet parallel with our weight
forward, we are in the starting position
for
communication when you're standing. Any
sport you have ever played has an
initial starting stance. This is the
starting stance for public speaking. If
you're being introduced, if you're
speaking with a team and you're standing
while someone else is speaking, this is
how you hold your body.
Now, of course, you'll move around if
you're standing. I recommend stepping in
towards the beginning of a
communication. So step towards your
audience with a broad gesture. That
makes you look very confident and
welcoming.
If somebody has a question or some
feedback, step towards them in an open,
neutral way. Again, making you look
confident.
And when you transition from one idea to
the next, physically move your body a
few steps and land back into this ready
position.
Now, often when you communicate, you're
not standing. You're seated. Same things
apply. Pull your shoulder blades down.
Make sure your head is straight. Keep
your feet flat on the ground. A lot of
us when we sit, we flex our legs a lot
and bounce around. You can see that
reflected in your shirt.
And have your arms on the table,
forearms on the table. We like to see
people's hands.
Speaking of hands,
what do we do with these things? It's
the number one question I get asked when
I teach people nonverbal presence.
I've already shared one place for them,
and that's down by your side.
It took me a long time, years, to be
comfortable talking with my hands down
by my side.
For many of us, it's much more
comfortable when we stand to put our
hands right at our belly button.
We want to avoid being too low.
This looks a little defensive, if you
get what I mean. And we want to avoid
our hands being up too high. This makes
us look like we're praying not to get
hurt.
So, placing your hands right at your
belly button, palm on palm,
interlacing the fingers, or even lightly
steepling, are nice places to rest your
hands.
We want to avoid doing anything that's
distracting or tentative with our hands.
We don't want to just hold the finger.
We don't want to crack our knuckles. We
want to avoid playing with rings. And we
don't want to do the heartbeat.
Nice and neutral. So, hands are either
down by our side or right at our
abdomen.
When you gesture, I have just one rule.
Go beyond your shoulders.
Many of us, when we're nervous, we
gesture in tight, between our shoulders.
How does it look if I say, "Here at our
company, we have a very open and
embracing culture."
Really?
Instead, I should say, "Here at our
company, we have an open and embracing
culture." Just going a little bit beyond
your shoulders makes you look open.
I like to tell people, think of your
chest as a basketball key. If you know
the rules of basketball, you can be in
the key for 3 seconds without getting a
penalty. So, I might say, "This is
really important to all of you
and me."
And then I return to my neutral place.
If I'm seated, I simply have my forearms
on the table, and when I gesture, I
gesture beyond my shoulders, and my arms
come back.
The final thing we need to talk about is
what do we do with our eye contact? We
need to make sure that when we
communicate, we look at the audience
that we're speaking to.
I am always asked, "How long should I
look at somebody?" And I wish I had a
good answer.
Long enough, but not too long.
Some people will say one idea per
person.
I struggle with that just because one
idea might be longer for one person than
another.
I recommend spreading your eye contact
around, but not in a patterned way.
How would it look if I just kept looking
across the audience like this?
A little strange. So, if you have a
large enough audience, let's say eight
or more, create quadrants of the area
you're speaking in. Maybe I look in the
back corner, then I'm here in the front,
and then maybe over here.
If it's a smaller group, certainly try
to look at each person.
Many of us, when we're trying to think
about what comes next, we will often
look up.
Because looking at people's faces is one
of the most drawn things that we do.
We're so motivated to learn about what's
on people's faces, that it's really hard
to think and take in all that
information.
So, it's very tempting to look up and
away. Unfortunately, when I look up and
away,
people see me as being distant, maybe
nervous, not wanting to be there.
It is better to look down than look up.
When I look down, I look thoughtful and
pensive. When I look up, I look
confused.
So, train yourself. If you have to take
a moment to look down, and then start
again.
A great way to do this is to move.
Often, when we need to think about what
we want to say next, is during points of
transition in our content. And as I
mentioned earlier, a great thing to do
when you're transitioning ideas is to
move laterally, side to side. So, as I
move, I might look down and walk. It's
very normal to look down as you walk, so
it looks completely natural.
So, taken together, when we work on our
presence, just our physicality, what we
do with our body, we can actually have a
big impact on how people perceive us.
Again, we want to be big, balanced, and
still. Pull the shoulder blades down,
have the arms to the side.
Head is straight and our feet are
parallel.
When we gesture, we gesture beyond our
shoulders, and we come to a neutral
resting place, either right in front of
our abdomen or down by our side. And
when we make eye contact, we look around
in a non-patterned way.
Taken together, these skills will help
you look confident and be composed while
you're communicating. The single best
tool to help you with this is to
digitally record yourself practicing.
And when you watch, turn the volume down
so you can see how you actually look and
how others will perceive you.
In so doing, you will begin to improve
your presence.
Thank you for joining us for this quick
[music] thinks episode of Think Fast,
Talk Smart, the podcast. To learn more
about [music] presence, please listen to
episode 12 with Deb Gruenfeld and
episode 137 [music]
with Dana Carney. This episode was
produced by Catherine Reed,
>> [music]
>> Ryan Campos, and me, Matt Abrahams. Our
music is from Floyd Wonder, with special
thanks to Podium Podcast Company. Please
find us on YouTube and wherever you get
your podcasts. Be sure to subscribe and
rate us. Also, follow us on LinkedIn,
Instagram, and check out fastermarter.io
for deep dive learning videos, education
in English learning content, and our
[music] newsletter. Please consider our
premium offering for extended deep
thinks, AMAs, and much more at
fastermarter.io/premium. [music]
You'll also find value by joining our
Think Fast, Talk Smart learning
community at fastermarter.io/learning.
[music]
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, and my
[music] AI coach along with book club
opportunities. Again, that's
fastermarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community. [music]